foreign
[Music]
Cosmic queries Edition Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
and a guy with me Chuck Nice Jack yo
what's up Miguel Jack is this themed or
is it un-themed Cosmic queries what do
you got for me today this is completely
un themed this is okay so grab this is
grab bag I think people like grab bags I
I assumes that it feels like that they
get totally into it you know why because
it's kind of like uh you know the prize
in a Happy Meal or a box of crackers you
don't know what you're gonna do okay
it's it's the Forest Gump of star talk
to Chocolate okay this is a box of
chocolates okay all right I don't know
what you gonna get she's a box of
chocolates who had the idea that you
could improve chocolate by putting a
gooey liquid that's not chocolate inside
of it this is a this is one of the
biggest mysteries of my life uh I'm sure
it was someone from the sugar industry
all that nasty chocolate yeah I know for
that chocolate oh let's put in a gooey
Cherry right it's corn syrup baby that's
what's that's where the action is
chocolate who wants that crap the horns
syrup and it's probably all cheaper than
the chocolate that would have been in
that volume in all of those candies a
hundred percent you know it that's right
I mean yeah good chocolate is expensive
man right there's a great place not too
far from where you live that they have
like just tremendously like high grade
chocolate no I know that place where
they where like they have a big window
you can see but it's like Willy Wonka or
something yeah and a good shot you know
as a cream making like Easter Bunnies
coming off the assembly line you know
with the factory line yeah yeah man yeah
all right all right
gr he says when on Star Trek they talk
about Subspace
what the hell are they talking about
okay so is it just a plot device is
Subspace a real thing what the hell is
going on thank you George Raider Randy
okay
so my answer is
I don't know we would need Charles Lou
for that
but what I can tell you is yes I think
it was a plot device because otherwise
they can't communicate
with anybody
okay ignoring whether it exists in
reality or could exist in reality I
don't even know how it works within the
world of Star Trek but you know Charles
Lew knows it so we'd have to like do an
emergency call to him
again
but as a plot point you need that
because without it how are they going to
talk back to you know headquarters or
because if you send a signal and they're
halfway across the Galaxy
that signal will take 50 000 years to
reach them yes and a round trip will
take a hundred thousand years if one of
them is in the middle of the Galaxy and
one is at the edge so you need some way
for signals to reach their destination
as though you're just having a phone
call with them and they're talking in
real time on basically real time correct
yeah yeah it's like so as I understand
it Subspace enables this otherwise
communication would just be pointless
and impossible
witty reparte would not be a thing we
can't even talk to Voyager uh
37 hours at a time it takes us to talk
to Voyager yeah exactly exactly yeah
exactly so so they so they had to figure
out how to get around that
and so so that's it all right George
radier or radier radio here we go this
is the artist formerly known as James
Smith and James says hey Neil hey Chuck
James from Indianapolis here so in the
very far future when a black hole is
done with Hawking radiation what is left
over once the black hole is gone does
the space in which the black hole
occupied have a large rip in it or is
the space around the black hole reverted
into the form which was there before the
black hole was formed thanks guys
do something to the fabric of space
where it makes everybody's wants to know
did the black hole leave a paw print
like black hole was here right right you
know or did it pee in that section of
the universe
yeah another black hole comes along
sniffs it and goes uh okay I either
gotta mark this or move on
so so uh it is an actual
literal evaporation I mean by a
different mechanism of course by Hawking
radiation but so the the size of the
Event Horizon as the black hole
uh shrinks from
Hawking radiation the size of the Event
Horizon shrinks with it it gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller and the nature of the radiation
that comes out
is you can approximate it by the
wavelength of the light that it emits is
approximately the same size as the size
of the Event Horizon itself oh wow so
big black holes give off radio waves as
Hawking radiation as they get smaller
and smaller they give off higher and
higher energy light so radio waves and
microwaves then infrared then red orange
yellow green blue violet ultraviolet
x-rays gamma rays so memories of the
tiniest wavelengths so as the black hole
gets littler and littler and littler the
evaporation rate increases and the
nature of the Hawking radiation changes
to become higher and higher energy
radiation did not know that yes so that
in the last instant it's just a puff of
gamma rays and then it disappears
completely that's amazing
and in fact I think the original paper
one of the original papers of Hawking
describes this as a source of gamma rays
in the universe that you might observe
right right right right that's really
cool man so it is a literal evaporation
like a pool of water drying up go except
you it might leave some residue like
mineral residue or something black hole
leave nowhere residue nothing needs
nothing right correct cool wow now the
weird thing is black holes there's some
mathematics
derived from Einstein that tells us that
on inside a black hole it opens up to
another Universe another space time
system and so if that's the case what
happens to that Universe when the black
hole evaporates
nice whoever was smoking weed in that
Universe up and it's over that little
universe is gone I saw that Universe
before I can't believe I saw this
universe man it was just right there in
my thumb so you're gonna write a book
the universe according to weed is that
yes good book
I'll call it astrophysics for Stoners in
a hurry
eat it okay that's so funny
that's true you'd never see anybody
rushing when they're high that is so
very urgency is not a matter when you
are stoned because I've been in a car
where the person driving with stone
and it's like they're driving real slow
it's like it's a funny thing let me stay
on the right hand side I'll drive real
slow so that no one will know I'm hot of
course and everybody knows like yeah
clearly yes they're as as tricycle past
you they know that you are tricycles get
on a tricycle passenger you know okay
this dude is stoned yeah yeah that's
cool all right what's next here we go
here we go here we go all right this is
David's sergeant
uh and he says and speaking of driving
look at what he says things start talk
make me contemplate while I'm driving
with the size of planets affecting space
time I.E gravity with cultures of huge
planets say the size of Jupiter only
solid have everything in life moving
slower so slow music for example or in
the opposite extreme a tiny planet
everything moving fast
uh so there you go yeah so he's talking
about general relativity what's the
person's name again
this is David sergeant David Sergeant so
so he's talking about he knows maybe he
might remember from the interstellar
film where they went down to a black
hole planet and they were deep in a
gravitational well and if you were in an
environment of high gravity time will
tick more slowly for you than if you're
in a place of load or no gravity so it's
relative okay right so
so planets
their gravity is not high enough for any
of the Big Planets little planets is not
high enough for any of this to make any
important difference in anybody's life
so don't confuse the fact that the black
hole planet in the film Interstellar was
in the gravitational well of the black
hole the black hole exactly Nicole was
doing the work not the plan the black
hole was doing the time dilation rather
than the planet itself so I if you're
just talking about planets orbiting the
same star or regular star this is not
something to think about or worry about
gotcha now what about
in Star Trek where the people from heavy
gravity planets are super strong with
would that be feasible that could happen
okay that could happen because you
whatever you weigh here on Jupiter I
forgot what on Jupiter it's a factor of
three or four maybe but so so if you
weigh let's say 150 pounds here you
weigh 500 pounds on a on a planet and so
if you were thriving there you'll have
muscles that will accommodate this extra
weight of your body you'll have really
thick stubby legs like uh I mean think
about if you want to be if you want to
be heavy you need
stuff like a hippopotamus right you know
like an elephant right no a giraffe is
big but they're not really all that
heavy right so they can get away with
these spindly legs I'm talking about big
chunky right you know
so if you put a giraffe on a heavy
Planet break its legs yeah the crust
itself Crush itself right correctly
where's it a hippo probably do just fine
right exactly no you don't know
so yeah so you have to your physiology
would have to be strong enough to
accommodate that and then you come to a
a light Planet like Earth
and you would be stronger than other
people probably is my guess
the I am from Jupiter okay
in a movie uh oh what was a movie that
this kid was born on Mars the space
between us
um there was a astronaut it takes about
nine months to get to Mars there's an
astronaut who got on board and I don't
remember the plot line whether she knew
or did not know if she was pregnant
okay or she like made love the night
before she went off but anyhow she gives
birth on Mars and NASA has to keep that
covered up because you you no you can't
so this kid was a secret kid raised on
Mars and then they brought him back like
in his teens and the Earth gravity was
like so Hep because Mars you weigh less
so he was feeling the stress of Earth's
gravity and yeah that actually sounds
like my life
I too had a secret kid
nope
I forgot all about that yeah that's what
this with with the maids with the maze
that's right
oh okay
you don't let nothing go by here no no
well listen I I he looked God God bless
him that's all I can say hi I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I'm Lindsay Nix
Walker senior producer of StarTalk and
Neil and I just co-authored a brand new
StarTalk book coming out September 12th
yeah this is the third in a series of
collaborations with National Geographic
books and this one is titled to infinity
and beyond and it's available for
pre-order from the StarTalk website
startalkmedia.com
books if you pre-order it you get to
gain access to a live stream that
Lindsay Walker and I will do from this
office and you have the occasion to
submit questions that we will answer
that's right if you pre-order from
startalkmedia.com books we'll answer
your questions about the book The
Universe Neil's favorite kind of cheese
whatever you want
foreign
all right so we'll see you there and
we'll see you then
why Coss says this hello Neil what's up
Chuck uh could the universe have started
off with a much higher initial entropy
if so how would the universe have been
different also what what's entropy
[Laughter]
thanks a million
I love that that that's pretty funny
okay so
um entropy is
um we quantify it in physics but in a
spoken way entropy is a way to measure
how disordered a system is
so if let's take you have a rectangular
box
and there's air inside the box and I
take all the air and shove it to one
half the Box okay and the other set part
of the Box there's like
there's nothing okay
that is more ordered
then it would become if I removed the
separator
from the middle of that box because you
know if I remove the separation what
would happen
all the air would just rush all over the
place and all the molecules in the air
would be like right yeah yeah it would
just become evenly spread throughout and
so because the air would just do that
naturally that is going from a high
ordered state
to a lower ordered state
and another one I have a a a glass of
water right and I take a drop of ink and
I drop it into one corner of the one
little bit and in that moment there's
ink here and there's water everywhere
else there's an ordering to that
okay because you can point to something
here and it's not there and that's over
there and it's not over here you give it
time the ink dissipates
every all the molecules that take it in
and the ink gets completely spread in my
eyes that's why we don't that's why we
don't want no ink moving in our
neighborhood because that's how it
happens
that's how it happens
starts off with one little house one
little ink house one little ink house
then before you know you got four or
five houses in your neighborhood hey
what's going on here now what's
happening to the schools oh wait a
minute so in my high school we had this
huge uh cylinder they call it graduated
cylinder right okay those those are the
educated ones the graduated it's an old
joke
old science joke anyhow so we had a huge
it was like three feet tall it was huge
and it was in one of the display cases
in most high schools in their display
case what do you find
trophies trophies of the sports but my
high school was the Bronx High School of
Science there were no Sports trophies
that's funny so so there's a huge
graduated cylinder and
there was a layer of ink at the bottom
and they slowly put water on top of it
and throughout the year you would watch
the ink work its way up into the
cylinder
so it was like a living exhibit of the
diffusion of of one liquid into another
nice rather than just stir it of course
stir it will happen but yeah so it'll do
that naturally it'll become higher
disorder than it previously had so
that's entropy okay okay so we were very
highly ordered at the beginning of the
universe because all the matter energy
was all in one place in one very
localized place as stuff expands
it's like the gas going into the other
half of them they like the ink going
into the thing
the entropy
um so it was highly ordered and so then
we go to High disorder as the universe
expands and so there you have it and the
end of the universe is total total
disorder no order at all there'll be no
machines no phenomenon because if
there's a phenomenon it means there's
order to make the phenomena making it
make it happen right okay if everything
is completely
spread out nothing can happen
so we will die
a a the universe will end not with a
bang but with a whimper and not in fire
but in ice look at that as the
temperature cools yeah so anyhow I mean
you can't get more ordered than the
universe occupying less than the size of
an atom so I you can't really adjust
that that's okay because everything is
very localized
okay okay so there you go uh that's it
all right oh by the way this the the
disorder
is natural
in a closed system so that box is a
closed system you can reverse entropy if
you add energy to it
okay oh we are alive
and our molecules are not scattered all
over the world we are a higher a higher
uh order of things than what preceded us
here on Earth okay okay so religious
communities for the longest while who
knew a little bit about this entropy
rule of thermodynamics said see we have
order and it's against the second law of
Thermodynamics and so therefore God made
us so you don't hear them give that
argument anymore because some of one of
them must have taught the others after
they took some Physics that Earth is not
a closed system you can't get a closed
system and have sunlight yes exactly I
mean we could only be a closed system
with a giant umbrella correct correct
completely enclosed Earth and watch what
happens all right so you take out the
base of the food chain which are all the
the plants that are undergoing
photosynthesis then you kill all of the
animals that depend on the plants so all
the herbivores the plants die first then
the herbivores then the animals that
live off the herbivores the Predators
they die and we all die and decompose in
the earth and there you have entropy at
work look at that that's
the coolest explanation of entropy I've
ever heard
and there's a way to quantify it with
equations but uh okay yeah all right
here we go this is Christian homes and
Christian Home says hello Dr Tyson Lord
nice I have a question about time
I recently learned from watching Dr
Brian Greene that the fabric of
space-time emerges from quantum
entanglement this explains that space is
woven of quantum wormholes but does that
mean time emerges also if so what
collection of quantum phenomena does
time emerge from or is time merely the
passing of one Quantum phenomena to the
next I really appreciate both of your
thoughts so
I too only recently learned from Brian
Greene the recent thinking this this
emergent thinking that the virtual
particles in the vacuum of space that
pop in and out of existence that they're
Quantum entangled while they are
separated and that quantum entanglement
May itself be this the thread that
Stitches the fabric of the space-time
Continuum but notice I said space time
so is it also stitching time and I don't
know the latest thinking on that
but if time according to Einstein was
invented to make motion look simple
then time is just something we create to
to measure the flow to measure sequences
of events to know what happened before
what and the intervals that separated
these events from those
so in that sense I don't know if time is
a fundamental property of space-time
or whether we've attached it afterwards
I don't know
there you have it
um uh now you guys you got some deeper
looking to do that's all
you gave Neil some homework Christian
no if you could one of these threads be
the time thread you know I don't know
right
what I do know is
threads you can always unweave
whereas for time as I said before we are
prisoners of the present right forever
transitioning between our inaccessible
past and our unknowable future let me
ask you this if we're prisoners of time
which we are of course meaning that you
know we can't go back undo things and go
forward again our our prison is One
Direction
what about dimensionally
let's say I'm a higher being in a higher
Dimension could I screw with our time in
this lower Dimension there's no reason
why you wouldn't so for example you're
you're inside a room there where you're
doing this recording right so if you had
access to a higher Dimension so you
could see the timeline right then you're
no longer a prisoner you can just you
can just I can join the timeline and do
whatever that's right so I'll give an
example so if let's say you're an aunt
and you're living in just two dimensions
and I draw a box around you sorry a
square around you you're in prison you
can't get out until the ant learns wait
a minute there's a third dimension let
me just go up into that third dimension
step out of the square and I'm free from
this prison
I can't believe you're saying this I
just saw this online two days ago where
somebody put an ant on a white piece of
paper as the ant crawled they took a
ballpoint uh fountain pen and they drew
and wherever they drew the ant would not
go it thought that it was blocked from
going there really okay yeah so cool
Edge okay so there it is so it does so
it has it's not thinking of a third
dimension to go up and around and over
it so you can imprison two-dimensional
creatures with a square
okay right because they don't know about
the third dimension now I am we can
imprison three-dimensional creatures
with a cube okay I put you in the cube
unless you have access to your timeline
if you had access to your timeline if
you step into the timeline occupy a
timeline when you're not in the cube go
back into your timeline and you just
escaped and you never had to open a door
or a window of your room to do so
amazing
I love it there it is
okay cool all right let's move on this
is uh C spinos uh and C spino says could
black holes just be wormholes I mean
do we just don't know I'm just thinking
out loud guys
sound like he wants black holes to be
wormholes hey that's I think that's what
he really wants is yeah yeah
so the first wormholes that were
imagined
were a black hole connecting to its
mathematical opposite a white hole and
you would connect them via a wormhole so
everything goes in the black hole and
comes out the white hole it's
mathematical opposite but then there's
more work done on wormholes especially
inspired by Carl Sagan's novel contact
when he was buds with with Kip Thorne a
a relativist physicist astrophysicist at
Caltech where you you run through more
of the equations and you can in
principle just punch a wormhole through
the fabric of space without reference to
a black hole or a white hole
but
you need some way to pry open space and
keep it there so you need like negative
negative matter
that can pull open space rather than
collapse space and so that works our
equations give it to you but we don't
know any substance such as negative
matter
so so wormholes are really just for now
the realm of Science Fiction
there you go look at that yeah but but
they do work out mathematically that's
fascinating yes they do yes they do
that's super cool man that is just super
cool all right this is anthroposcopic
Dylan love it anthroposcopic I'm sorry
anthropocosmic
anthropocosmic Dylan okay greetings Dr
Tyson and Dr comedy Neil build off of
your past Star Talk episodes can you
talk about the lineage of the Stars how
are the elements that we are made of
connected to our son's generation or put
another way the cosmic and Stellar
evolution of the universe thank you
Dylan from San Diego I love it so in my
in my field we've binned
the star populations into
[Music]
three three
for
yeah four groups
and just so with Roman numerals except
we have a zero and the Romans didn't
have zero right so there's no zero in
Roman numerals no zero in room that's
why there's no zero in the Julian
calendar where they try to put the birth
of Jesus at the beginning of the
calendar there's no zero it went from
one BC to ad1 so anyhow you know
invented the zero or the uh Hindus had
invented the zero then it it migrated to
Baghdad and then the Arabs did great
things with it and you know fully
developing algebra and uh another thing
bam that's a whole other aside so nice
the first stars in the universe we call
those population
three
okay
population three
yes well sorry the Stars right here we
call those population one
okay
population one
what does that mean it stars like the
Sun have a certain amount of heavy
elements in it you can measure them how
much iron silicon nitrogen oxygen
heavier than hydrogen and helium okay as
we looked in certain parts of the Galaxy
we found stars that had way less heavy
elements
we call those population two
population two
but these did not have the benefit of
multiple generations of stars before
them only maybe a couple of generations
of stars enriching their heavy element
abundance
one those are pop two and someone said
well let's imagine a pop three which
would be the very first stars and they
have no heavy elements
at all right
so we are by this measure a third
generation
um
star says and if a star born today we
might call that
pop four
I know am I doing it the right way no
problem sorry Pop zero right yeah we
might call it pop zero we should have
probably numbered it the other way but
it's the other way so we could keep
going yeah keep going yeah yeah
and and the stars that look like cute
little boys that make girl screams would
be K-pop
I'm sorry I didn't I shouldn't have done
that I don't know what the hell I was
thinking what I just one two three and
K-pop yeah
it was crazy it was I went to a K-pop
concert not too long ago there it is and
I'm scarred that's what it is you're
absolved okay
all right let's go back to our questions
and this is Ryan a he says greetings
Neil greeting your lordship my this is
Ryan from Ontario Canada here Neil you
once said you had an answer to the
simulation Theory where either we are
first or the last in the series and
since we haven't invented the ability
yet it can't be real however
what if the simulation is not produced
by our species but another in the
universe thanks for making my brain
bigger every week Neil so there you go
that's Ryan a who wants to know are you
yeah so if someone else is creating us
that's fine however it only it only
works as something that's that's scary
if it's self-propagating all right
that's that's the whole idea here the
the original authentic Universe creates
a model
you know a computer universe and that
they believe they have free wills and
then they create one and they create one
and is that all the way down until the
last one which hasn't evolved yet to
create one
so this is a real universe creating
fake universes right what you're saying
is you want just a super intelligent
species that has super computers they're
all Quantum and they're fine but then
they could make us we have to make a
different one and they make another one
and that's right that's more effort so
yeah it could be
I'm not denying that but that was that
you don't get this sort of runaway
effect where everybody's making versions
of itself within their own Computing
system
right okay yeah yeah your way is more
fun is what you're saying this is
all right this is uh Joe ingrassia and
Joe and Gracia says this hey Neil hey
Chuck uh this is Joe from Missouri if
you're in space where you are not
affected by any gravity how do you know
if you're going up down left right or
any direction if you don't have any
instruments to tell you okay first of
all
nobody said there's no gravity in space
this is one of the biggest delusions
that pervades our culture and our
storytelling yeah Joe why are you so
delusional
you go into space on route to the Moon
you can't say there's no gravity there
because
what do you think the Moon is orbiting
right okay
the moon feels our gravity and is in
orbit around us
this whole notion that space has no
gravity comes about because though
because of the way we travel between
destinations in space you know how we do
it
I'm gonna head for Mars I'm gonna fire
my engines right now cut them off and
Coast To Mars if you're coasting
anywhere in the universe you are
weightless
period
right but if you turn on the engines
you're going to feel some g-forces and
that g basically counts as weight
according to your body so you have
weight that way you you
um that's if you want to get anywhere
fast
and what was the film that where they
had the moon pirates that crazy film uh
Ed Astro in the film add Ashton yes Brad
Pitt was that that was in Brad Pitt yeah
yeah
so they have these scenes where
everyone's just weightless in their
spaceship even though the engines are
firing right it doesn't work sorrow is
their belief that being in space makes
you weightless so that's the first point
second
down
it's whichever direction you're
following okay
that's funny right that's funny
so if you're coasting towards the Moon
down is towards the moon right
all right I think it's that simple that
makes a lot of sense yeah
all right super cool super cool Chuck
let's do one more and then we gotta
close the episode all right here we go
this is Walker foland and Walker folin
says hello Dr Tyson Lord nice this is
Walker fallen from West Branch Michigan
recently I read that the fabric the
fabric of space-time maybe wormholes
that be that are entangled between
particles is it possible that like the
previous question like this is getting
around people are on to this man uh is
it possible the correlation of mass and
gravitational pull have to do with the
number of entangled particles that are
particles that are in that Mass
in other words the more dense a body is
the more entangled particles it has
therefore the more micro wormholes would
go to that mass could this explain the
very nature of gravity and why its
relations and its relation to time I
imagine that wormholes would act as a
conduit for Mass to accumulate I would
love to hear your thoughts
I gotta think about that
I gotta you know we do we'll hold that
question next time we bring a drag Brian
Green yeah exactly which would cost me
craze so what he's saying is if the
wormholes are part of the fabric of
space and time and wormholes can attract
objects to them and not only other
wormholes but just more stuff
could that in fact be what causes
gravity and I don't have an answer for
that yeah that's pretty that's a pretty
wild question bro I got to give it to
you uh well how about Margaret Berry
here uh so now we gotta have Brian Green
on thanks for giving us a reason to have
um
okay uh here's Margaret Berry she says
hi Chuck hi Neil uh this is Margaret
from North Carolina my question is this
if all forms of energy have both
particle and wave attributes doesn't
this itself Define string theory
oh
no
and that's our show people thank you so
much
uh strings are one-dimensional
um
concentrations of energy
living in a higher Dimension and yes
they vibrate and depending on how they
vibrate they will
manifest as one kind of particle or
another
a wave however is not a string
right okay
it's just not
so I don't know that you can connect
the way
with the strings that you'd find in
strength yeah I don't think you can do
that yeah okay well there you go
Margaret I mean it was a nice try again
that was a nice try Marcus he was like
I'm on to something
um
like listen
I figured out the string theory
no that was that was a very cool very
cool Market thank you all right that's
what we have so that was a patreon
members at five dollars a month get you
access to this so listen people and I
think those numbers are growing so
people like uh maybe this is the carrot
that everybody needed I don't know but
yeah the numbers okay let me just tell
you we we got through a lot today we
don't normally get through this many
questions I think I'm getting better at
shortening my answers we got through a
lot so all right the patreon thing is
working for those of you who want to uh
uh submit your questions go to
patreon.com Star Talk and uh sign up for
the five dollar uh level the teamwork
and uh for that for the cup for the
price of a cup of coffee
uh you can go ahead and be a part of our
patreon family all right that's all the
time we got for it chuck all righty all
right this is a bit of the Star Talk
Cosmic queries grab bag Edition always
fun Neil deGrasse Tyson here as always
[Music]